did you spot the nazi references in the
lion king or the 2001 homage in wally
bowie in moana these are just a few of
the many things that only adults notice
about cartoon villains
the cartoon network series the powerpuff
girls might just be the cutest take ever
on superheroes debuting in 1998 blossom
bubbles and buttercup are kindergarten
aged children who protect their town as
super powered beings the girls have a
great rogues gallery filled with
villains who are often just as brightly
drawn and cute as the heroines from
princess morbucks to mojo jojo but
amidst all that cuteness lies a
disturbing anomaly known as his infernal
majesty or simply him this strange red
creature has a soft seductive voice
horn-like ears a goatee and thigh-high
boots that look an awful lot like hooves
and his aim isn't world domination it's
to corrupt the powerpuff girls innocent
natures in other words he's satan not
exactly what you usually expect from a
kid's cartoon
dr hines doofenshmirtz is the main
villain of phineas and ferb which began
airing in 2007 a classic mad scientist
with improbable inventive skills
doofenshmirtz's dearest wish is to
conquer the tri-state area doofenshmirtz
doesn't have a lot of friends or family
but he is deeply attached to his
daughter vanessa he can often be seen
worrying about her and saving her from
trouble and he even gives up being evil
for her sake in the series finale all of
that makes doofenshmirtz one of the top
parents in cartoon history despite being
viewed as an evil villain in fact
doofenshmirtz is a far better parent
than even phineas and ferb's parents
every episode of the show has the boys
engaging in an outrageous adventure with
no adult around to stop them from
building roller coasters messing with
time travel engineering giant robots or
traveling between dimensions seriously
the attitude of phineas and ferb's
parents borders on the neglectful
especially when compared to the lengths
that doofenshmirtz goes to while trying
to protect vanessa
disney fairy tales tend to stay away
from lewdness keeping in mind their very
young audience most disney villains are
motivated by pg-13 impulses like a
desire for magical power or wealth not
so with judge frollo the main villain of
1996 is the hunchback of notre dame
frollo was all kinds of messed up as the
minister of justice frollo was highly
disturbed by the unusual passions
awakening in his bosom at the sight of
the beautiful esmerelda in fact frollo
sings an entire song hellfire about how
hot he is for esmerelda how his feelings
are her fault and how he will not rest
until he gets with her whether she's
into him or not
it's extremely disturbing watching a
disney character sing about his desire
to assault the heroine how this film got
a g rating is a mystery to everyone
sid phillips from 1995's toy story
managed to be a terrifying villain
despite only being an 11 year old kid
that was because sid delighted in
breaking apart toys and reconstructing
them in grotesque horrific ways the
obvious pleasure sid takes in mutilating
beautiful little toys would sound alarm
bells for any psychiatrist as well as
child protective services sid displays
classic signs of a child who has
suffered neglect and abuse
in the movie we get a brief glimpse of
sid's father asleep on a reclining chair
a deer head mounted on the wall shows
that mr phillips likes to inflict
violence on others the fact that he is
asleep in the middle of the day shows he
is likely jobless and the many empty
beer cans littering the room likely
indicate an alcoholic who doesn't take
care of his surroundings all these hints
alongside sid's fear of waking his
father up point towards the philips
household being an unhappy one how much
of sid's sadistic impulses are the
result of his father may be debatable
but this much is clear the kid is
seeking an outlet for his anger by
herding toys
disney often makes use of pop culture
icons while creating their animated
characters a trend that included 2016's
moana via tamatoa a giant flamboyant
crab that craves shiny valuable objects
for older viewers tamatoa's look might
evoke memories of iconic glam rock
singer songwriter david bowie and that
is no accident the look of tamatoa was
in fact based on bowie and the
character's big musical number shiny was
written with bowie in mind as the film
songwriter lin manuel miranda told
people in 2016 i'd been listening to
bowie on a loop i was like well i'm
writing a glam rock tune for this crap
this jewel encrusted crab to channel the
spirit of bowie further tamatoa was
voiced by new zealand's jermaine clement
who has been known to bust out a
credible impression of bowie in projects
like flight of the concords clement told
the au review when i tried to record
shiny in the character's voice miranda
just kept pushing the bowie thing do it
more bowie he wanted glam like a t-rex
bowie
ursula from 1989's the little mermaid is
as rollickingly entertaining as a disney
villain can get which makes sense
because she was based on a rollickingly
entertaining drag queen rob minkoff
animator for the little mermaid revealed
in the 2020 disney plus documentary
howard that he came up with a host of
possible designs for ursula's character
including one based on famed drag queen
divine best known for playing edna in
1988's hairspray when the film's
lyricist howard ashman saw the drawings
the choice was clear and that design was
put on a board with a bunch of other
designs and then the day that howard
ashman came in to look at the designs he
zeroed in on that one truly divine
1994's the lion king is generally agreed
to be one of the greatest disney movies
of all time despite being a story about
talking animals the movie was grounded
in mature themes as it took its cues
from the biblical stories of joseph and
moses william shakespeare's hamlet and
also from the infamous nazi propaganda
films of lenny riefenstahl in the song
be prepared sung by the movie's main bad
guy scar we see hyenas marching past the
villainous lion in a highly regimented
style the movements of the hyenas and
the view of their formations was based
specifically on nazi propaganda films by
riefenstahl according to entertainment
weekly the idea for the song came from a
sketch by story staffer jorgen clabin
that pictured scar as hitler which
inspired the directors to craft the be
prepared sequence which became one of
the most iconic parts of the film pixar
is a studio that excels in telling
stories filled with warmth and empathy
stanley kubrick was a filmmaker renowned
for telling stories filled with tension
coldness and dread the two might not
seem to have much of an overlap at first
blush but 2008's wally brought the two
together in an unexpected manner through
the introduction of its main villain in
wali the central antagonist is a rogue
ai called auto that has control of a
vessel carrying humanity into the
furthest reaches of space otto's looks
and personality are clearly based on the
villainous hal 9000 from kubrick's 2001
a space odyssey but the references don't
end there a scene from 2001 where an ape
learns to use tools features the same
music as the scene in wall-e when the
captain of otto's space vessel finally
leaves his chair to stand on his feet
learning self-reliance in the process
after having depended on otto for
everything for so many years
2005's disney film chicken little was a
heartfelt story about growing up
standing up for your beliefs and
learning to let your children become
self-reliant and it also paid homage to
one of the most influential terrifying
sci-fi novels of all time h.g wells 1897
masterpiece the war of the worlds which
features aliens landing in terrifying
tripods fortunately the machines in
chicken little were a lot more benign
than the ones that showed up in the war
of the worlds it is revealed in the
final act of the movie that the aliens
initially visited earth just to gather
acorns and later returned with an entire
armada because they thought one of their
own was being held hostage by earthlings
once the misunderstanding is cleared up
the aliens returned peacefully to their
home planet
for multiple generations of children the
tom and jerry cartoons have been a
popular retelling of the classic david
vs goliath narrative in this case the
big dimwitted cat tom is the evil
goliath while the smaller quick-witted
jerry is plucky little david who humbles
the giant with his brains and willpower
but is the story really that simple once
you grow up and need to look into buying
or renting your own house you begin to
realize what a major problem house pests
like mice can be which is why house pets
like cats are used to eliminate pests
and keep the home safe once you start
looking at the situation from that angle
you realize that jerry was the villain
of the show an uninvited house pest that
ran roughshod all over the house eating
and taking whatever he wanted meanwhile
tom was simply the house pet trying to
do what it had been trained to
accomplish keeping the home safe from
unwanted rodents sure tom was always
left frustrated after his encounters
with jerry but just imagine how tom's
owners must have felt so if you think
jerry is the good guy all we can say is
adult innuendo in cartoons aimed at
children is not a new thing but
sometimes the innuendo is so in your
face you can't help but be surprised by
the audacity of the show's writers case
in point roxy rocket's appearance in the
new batman adventures where she had a
singular obsession with getting laid in
the episode the ultimate thrill viewers
are introduced to roxy a daredevil stunt
woman who turned to a life of crime to
satisfy her craving for excitement in
roxy's mind her reaction to danger is
quite similar to arousal roxy's weapon
of choice is a giant phallic rocket and
she soon becomes obsessed with batman
throughout the episode roxy makes one
charged comment after another telling
penguin about batman quote i was the
best he ever had and i love a man with
staying power but the most brazen scene
comes at the end when roxy's last daring
heist is stopped by batman she appears
to be in the throes of ecstasy me and
you
yeah
yeah
yeah 2010's despicable me had you
rooting for the bad guy felonious gru
was an aspiring supervillain who dreamed
of pulling off the ultimate heist to
prove himself so he was forced to go to
the bank of evil an organization that
offers loans to supervillains who can
prove their schemes are sufficiently
evil however the entrance to the bank is
hidden behind a urinal but the truly
dastardly touch is that the entrance is
behind the middle urinal when you go to
a public restroom most people's instinct
is to use the urinal to the left or the
right because that minimizes the chance
of having to pee standing next to
someone only someone truly evil and
twisted would willingly use the middle
urinal where he could be flanked on both
sides by others it is exactly that kind
of dastardly mind that the bank of evil
would be interested in doing business
with
the evil queen from 1937 snow white and
the seven dwarves might just be the most
iconic disney villain of all time
she's often portrayed as the
personification of evil but adults might
be more likely to diagnose her as
suffering from narcissistic personality
disorder npd also referred to as
megalomania is a mental condition which
has been officially recognized by the
american psychiatric association people
suffering from npd have an exaggerated
sense of their own importance as well as
a deep need for excessive attention and
admiration this in turn leads to the
sufferer having trouble maintaining
relationships due to a lack of empathy
for others these symptoms fit the evil
queen to a t the tragic part is npd is
actually treatable but the people who
suffer from it have such a high opinion
of themselves that they refuse to
recognize they have a problem that
requires therapy the evil queen's time
could have been put to much better use
if she had stopped obsessing over snow
white so much and booked an appointment
with the dwarf named doc instead
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one